suffira-t-elle à adoucir une année
compliquée pour lui aussi en tout cas
cette distinction en fait désormais l'un
des chefs incontournable de l'hexagone
christophe est déjà deux étoiles au
michelin a été désigné aujourd'hui
meilleur cuisinier 2021 pour le
prestigieux gault et millau le
propriétaire de la maison d'à côté à
montlivault couronné pour sa cuisine
raffinée de produits locaux
lucas chopin c'est une distinction de
plus sur sa devanture
depuis aujourd'hui christophe et le
cuisinier de l'année pour le prestigieux
guide gault et millau et en cuisine
le rythme ne diminue pas si on va faire
pomme de terre truffe on a un créneau de
pommes de terre avec avec la truffe on a
les lamelles de pommes de terre là avec
un un petit colis de truffes en fait
donc des trucs qu'on a pulvérisé sa
cuisine deux étoiles christophe et la
propose désormais à emporter confinement
oblige pour autant pas question de
changer la recette tout et locales et
même très local landais son jardin le
jardin c'est c'est pour nous un vrai
joli lien il ya toujours un moment où il
ya une personne de l'équipe qui descend
chercher des produits pour nous c'est ya
rien qui traîne en sombres et froides en
fait dès qu'on a besoin de quelque chose
on voit le chercheur tous les légumes
sont cultivés sur place et les bêtes
élevées à proximité je suis un amoureux
du végétal je suis un amoureux de la
terre parce que voilà de 2,2 de part mon
enfance passée à la ferme
il ya aussi ce lien qui est très fort ce
sont six ans d'un travail acharné du
chef et qui ont fait son succès et c'est
sans doute ce qui a plu à gault et
millau cuillé de l'année sur une année
comme 2020 on pourrait se dire que c'est
assez bizarre mais finalement non s'est
jamais arrêté en tous les cas moi
le fait de prendre ma voiture le matin
et de venir travailler c'est quelque
chose qui est primordial en fait on
aujourd'hui on vient pas en cuisine on
vient pas ouvrir nos établissements pour
pour cette distinction
on travaille pas pour ça en tout les cas
mais mais c'est vrai que quand on les
reçoit c'est c'est quelque chose de
superbe christophe et se sent comblée et
espère entendre les bruits de ses
clients en salle dès la fin du mois de
janvier